こんしゅうのざっくばらんな話題として、まずはJevがエルエルエムとどこが違うのか、というところからお話しします。
二週間ほど前にTypeSafe エーアイから発表されたJevが、今とても注目されていて、大きなムーブメントになっています。
Jevは、TypeSafe エーアイが「System Oneモデル」と呼ぶ新しい種類のエーアイモデルなんです。
その名前は、人間の直感的で素早い思考を指す心理学の用語「システム1」に由来しています。
いままで、オープンエーアイやアンソロピックなどが提供している大規模言語モデル、つまりエルエルエムを中心に動いていたエーアイ業界の重心が、ここにきて大きくシフトしたような感覚があります。
2025年に中国からDeepSeekというエーアイが発表された際には、その開発コストの安さが話題になって、「DeepSeekショック」と呼ばれるほど、かぶしきしじょうに大きな影響を与えましたが、私は今回のJevがぎょうかい全体に与えるインパクトの方がはるかに大きいと感じています。
Jevは、自然言語で書かれた文章、いわゆるプロンプトを入力として受け取りしょりするという点ではエルエルエムと同じですが、次のような点が大きく異なります。
まず一つ目、推論スピードが桁違いに速くてコストも安いこと。
そして二つ目、文章は生成せず、指定された質問に対して確率で答えることです。
例えば、「今回購入したばかりの乾燥機の乾きが悪い」といった入力に対して、「処理すべきなのは、A:営業、B:サポート、C:サービス、D:財務」といった質問を投げたとします。
エルエルエムの場合なら、「お客様が購入したばかりの乾燥機の乾きが悪いと主張しているのであれば、使い方の問題の可能性もあるので、まずはサポート部門で受けるのが妥当です。
そこで、故障と判断すればサービスに回します」といった言葉で答えてくれます。
一方で、Jevはどうするかというと、
[EN]A:1%, B:58%, C:41%, D:0%[/EN]
と確率で返してくれるんです。
人間が読む場合は、エルエルエムの方が便利ですが、プログラムで自動的にしょりする場合だと、Jevのように確率で出してくれる方が扱いやすいんですね。
例えば、確率が70パーセント以上であれば自動的に仕分けて、それ以外は人間が判断する…この例ではBが58パーセントなので、人間が判断することになります。
エルエルエムを使った場合でも、ツール呼び出し、いわゆるTool CallやMCPを使えば同じような自動仕分けはできますが、やっぱり多くの文字列、つまりトークンを生成しなければならないぶん、時間とコストがかかりますし、確信度も分かりにくいため、どこまで自動化して良いかの判断が難しくなるんです。
ここまでならすぐに理解できたんですが、どうしてこんな便利なことが、エルエルエムよりも速く、しかも安くできてしまうのかを理解するまでには少し時間がかかりました。
ここからは、私なりの解説をしたいと思います。
私が理解に役立ったのは
[EN]Build your own Jev (100% local)[/EN]
というX上の投稿です。
例えていうなら、エルエルエムは答案用紙に記述式で一文字ずつ答えを書き込んでいくような感じですが、Jevはマークシートの選択肢それぞれに「自信度」を付けるだけなんです。
書く量が桁違いに少ないので、速くて安いのは当然ですよね。
もう少し技術的に説明すると、エルエルエムのすいろんは大きく分けて二つのフェーズで行われます。
一つ目は、入力されたプロンプトをしょりしてKV Cacheと呼ばれる一時記憶を作る「Prefill」。
そして二つ目が、KV Cacheにもとづいて出力トークンを一つずつ生成する「Decode」です。
ここでいうトークンは、言葉でいう単語だと思ってくれれば十分です。
Prefillの方はたくさんの計算資源が必要になりますが、並列しょりが可能なので、ジーピーユーが多ければ高速にしょりできます。
一方で、Decodeは、一トークンずつ順番にしょりしないといけないうえ、大量のデータを動かす必要があるので、計算資源よりもデータの転送スピードがボトルネックになる、という特徴があるんです。
それぞれのエルエルエムには決まった語彙数、たとえば十五万語が登録されていますが、Decodeのときにはその全部に「logit」と呼ばれる重み、つまりふさわしさを計算し、そのうち最大のものを選んでKV Cacheをアップデートすることを、トークン一つごとに繰り返して文字列を生成します。
結果的に、とても膨大な時間がかかるんですね。
つまり、エルエルエムのコストの大半は、出力トークンの数だけDecodeを繰り返すことにあるわけです。
一方でJevの場合は、質問の形をあらかじめ決めておけば、Prefillのさいごで得られる内部状態から、候補になる語彙、つまりA、B、C、Dの四つのlogitだけをパッと計算して、これを確率の形に変換して返すだけで済むんです。
だから、エルエルエムで膨大なデータ転送や出力トークンの繰り返し計算が必要だったDecode自体を、まるごと省略できるんです。
エーアイぎょうかいでは、エルエルエムのDecodeプロセスでメモリやデータの転送スピードがボトルネックになったことで、メモリの価格が急上昇したり、メモリ関連の株価が跳ね上がったりしましたが、判断や分類系のワークロードに関しては、Jev、あるいはJevと同じようなせっけいのモデルを使えば、そのボトルネックが実質的に解消されてしまうわけです。
もちろん、すべてのケースでJevが使えるわけじゃなくて、これからもエルエルエムは幅広く使われ続けますが、とくにエンタープライズしじょうなど、さまざまな判断を自動化したい場面ではJevスタイルのエーアイモデルが理にかなっているので、アプリケーション・アーキテクチャが大きく変化するのは間違いないと私は思っています。
TypeSafe エーアイは、つい先日、約二億ドルの企業価値で四千万ドルの資金を調達したことを発表したばかりなんですが、今回のリリースの成功を受けて、さらに大きな資金調達に動くと予想されています。
ただ、既にJevと同じようなパフォーマンスを持つオープンモデルが次から次に発表されていて、一気にコモディティ化が進む可能性も十分あるので、今後も目が離せません。
なかでも注目したいのが、パソコンで動かせる規模のJevスタイルのモデルです。
高速で軽量な判断ができるモデルがパソコンで動くとなれば、応用範囲が一気に広がります。
とくに画像もしょりできるマルチモーダルなモデルになると、いままでコスト面で難しかったセキュリティカメラへのリアルタイムな応用、たとえば万引き防止なども、現実的な選択肢になってきます。
続いて、材料シミュレーションエーアイ「Matlantis PFP」とPFNの垂直統合戦略についてです。
せんしゅう号で医療や素材の分野において、エーアイは24時間休まず大量の実験を繰り返せる強みがあるけれど、実際の実験装置を使う必要があると、そこがボトルネックになると書いたばかりでした。
その意味では、シミュレーション技術がこれからますます重要になると言ったんですが、今回はそのニーズにピッタリ合う研究をしている日本の企業を見つけたので紹介します。
サービスの名前はMatlantisです。
提供しているのは、最初から独立系スタートアップとして生まれた会社ではなくて、Preferred Networks（PFN）とENEOS、日本最大の石油・エネルギー会社が共同で研究して作った技術を、外販向けに切り出したジョイントベンチャーなんですね。
このプロジェクトの出発点は2019年です。
PFNの深層学習やニューラルネットの技術をENEOSの研究開発に使えないかという勉強会から始まって、特に難しかった触媒かいはつをエーアイで高速化できないか、というところから、両社の間で「エーアイを使った汎用原子シミュレーター」の共同かいはつが始まりました。
通常、材料の原子レベルのシミュレーションにはDFT、つまり密度汎関数理論という手法を使います。
これは量子力学にもとづいて原子や電子のふるまいをコンピューターで計算する方法ですが、精度がとても高いかわりに計算量がものすごく大きいんです。
たとえば原子の数が十倍になると、計算時間が千倍になってしまうという「三乗の壁」があり、大きな構造を扱うのがむずかしいという欠点があります。
そこで、DFTの計算結果を教師データとしてニューラルネットを作ることで、原子間のエネルギーや力を高速に推定するのが「PFP（PreFerred Potential）」という技術です。
このPFPの開発で一番手間がかかったのは、学習データを作るところだったそうです。
投入したジーピーユーの計算資源は、のべ三千二百年分以上。
訓練データは六千三百万以上の原子構造、さらに複雑な構造になると、一つのDFT計算にジーピーユーで丸一日かかるとのことです。
PFPの特徴は、ニューラルネットワークのなかに物理法則を直接組み込んでいる点です。
たとえば、分子を回転させてもエネルギーが変わらないという「回転不変性」を、高階テンソルといった数学的な道具を使って保証しています。
その結果、物理的にありえない答えをそもそもエーアイが出力できない設計になっています。
そして、共同研究がかたちになったところで、2021年6月にPFNが五十一パーセント、ENEOSが四十九パーセントを出資、資本金は三億一千万円で株式会社Preferred Computational Chemistry、略してPFCCを設立しました。
PFPを「Matlantis」というクラウドサービスとして販売も始めていて、2025年7月には社名も株式会社Matlantisに変更しています。
2024年6月には三菱商事がPFCCと資本業務提携して株主になり、海外販売や素材産業への営業面で、自社のグローバルネットワークを提供するかたちです。
利用する企業や研究機関の数の推移を見てみると、
2023年4月時点で50を超え、
2024年4月時点で80を超えています。
今回は、週刊Life is beautiful、二千二十六年十月六日号です。
Jevはエルエルエムとどこが違うのか、PFNの垂直統合戦略、AMDによるWorld Labsの買収、ホワイトハウスのエーアイ安全協定、今回はそのパート二です。
まず、二千二十六年現在、PFPの導入企業は百五十社を超えて、順調に推移しています。
直感的にも、とても筋が良いビジネスのように見えるんですよね。
PFPの性能を決めるのは、教師データの量と質なんですが、その作成には莫大な計算資源に加えて、「どの構造を計算すべきか」を設計する専門家の知見が不可欠なんです。
データの九割以上は、研究者が用途を考えて設計した「ハンドメイド」だと言われています。
こうした事情が、新規参入の大きな障壁となって、PFNの競争力の強みになっているということなんです。
ここまで調べてみて、じつは親会社のPFN自体の最近の動きの方が、さらに面白いことに気づきました。
二千二十六年に入ってからのPFNは、以前は「ディープラーニングの技術会社」だったのが、今は半導体、計算基盤、エーアイモデル、さらに産業向けアプリケーションまでを自社で垂直統合する会社へと、はっきり方向転換しているんです。
その象徴とも言えるのが、九月十八日に発表された、MatlantisをPFNが独自開発したエーアイプロセッサー「MN-Core 2」の上で動かすという発表です。
いちぶの計算では、ジーピーユーよりも最大で約四倍も速くなるとされていて、二千二十六年中の提供が予定されています。
これが実現すれば、Matlantisは次のように、チップから顧客まで、すべてがPFNグループ内で完結するサービスになるんです。
半導体はMN-Core 2、
[EN]計算基盤はPFNのクラウド（PFN Computing Infrastructure）[/EN]、
エーアイモデルはPFP、七月には、より高精度なR2SCANという計算条件に対応したv9をリリースし、九十六元素まで計算できるようになりました。
サービスはMatlantis、
顧客には素材、化学、自動車メーカーなど、VolkswagenやHyundaiもすでに導入しているそうです。
チップ開発の方も、単なる「自社スーパーコンピューター用」から、今後は事業の柱へと進化しつつあります。
二千二十七年に発売予定の次世代チップ「MN-Core L」シリーズは、ロジック、つまり計算回路と、比較的安いディーラム、これはパソコンなどに使われる一般的なメモリですが、これを垂直に積み重ねることで、MN-Core 2の五十倍以上のメモリ帯域、つまりデータを読み書きできる速さを目指しているんです。
冒頭でも話したように、Jevの話でエルエルエムのDecodeはメモリとデータの転送スピードがボトルネックになる、という指摘がありましたが、まさにそれを正面から解決しようとしている設計なんですよね。
PFNは、トヨタ未来創生センターとこのチップを使った共同研究も始めていて、ロボットの中で大きなエーアイモデルをリアルタイムで動かすことを狙っているんです。
エーアイモデルの開発も進んでいて、国産エルエルエムの「PLaMo」から、画像も理解できるモデル、さらにはロボットが「ここは走っていい」「ここは進入禁止」といった周囲の環境を理解できる基盤モデル、PLaMo-SemGroundにも広がっています。
こうした方向性を見ると、ロボットや機械など現実世界で体を持って動く「フィジカルエーアイ」の領域にシフトしているのが、はっきりと分かります。
しかも、九月十六日には三菱重工との資本業務提携も発表され、三菱重工から百億円もの出資を受けることになったんです。
航空、防衛、宇宙、発電設備など、「現実世界の巨大な機械」を持つ三菱重工と、エーアイモデルやエーアイチップを持つPFNが組むのは、フィジカルエーアイのパートナーとしては理想的な組み合わせと言えます。
日本のエーアイスタートアップの多くは、エヌビディアのジーピーユーと、オープンエーアイやアンソロピックのモデルの上にアプリケーションを作る、というやり方を採用しています。
でも、PFNは半導体から、そこで動くエーアイモデル、さらにその上の産業向けアプリケーションまで全部自分たちで作るという、世界でもなかなか見られない会社になりつつあるんです。
これまでバラバラに見えていたそれぞれの取り組みが、二千二十六年になって、「フィジカルエーアイのための垂直統合スタック」としてつながり始めているのが印象的です。
Matlantisは、そのスタックが最初に形になった事例だと言えるでしょう。
参考資料として、「物理を再現するエーアイ」で材料開発の常識を変える──「Matlantis PFP」はいかにして生まれたか、Matlantisが汎用原子レベルシミュレータの中核技術「Matlantis PFP」をv9にアップデートしたニュース、PFNがトヨタ未来創生センターとエーアイ半導体MN-Core Lシリーズを活用したフィジカルエーアイの高速化に関する共同研究を始めた話、PFNとPFRが屋内移動ロボット向けの環境高度理解基盤モデルPLaMo-SemGroundを共同開発開始した話などがあります。
そして、
[EN]Mitsubishi Heavy Industries and Preferred Networks Form Capital and Business Alliance[/EN]
というお知らせもありました。
続いて、AMDによるWorld Labsの買収についてです。
せんしゅう、AMDがFei-Fei Li博士が立ち上げたWorld Labsを買収すると発表しました。
Li博士はAMDのエグゼクティブバイスプレジデント兼チーフサイエンティストに就任し、共同創業者のJustin JohnsonさんとBen Mildenhallさんも引き続きAMD内でWorld Labsを率いていくことになりました。
この買収は規制当局の承認を経て、二千二十六年末までに完了する予定です。
[EN]World Labs is Joining AMD[/EN]
Li博士は、画像認識の大規模データセット「ImageNet」を創設したことで、今のエーアイの発展の礎を作った人物です。
ImageNetは、これまでにない規模、なんと一千四百万枚以上のラベル付き画像データベースで、これを活用して行われた「ImageNet大規模視覚認識チャレンジ（ILSVRC）」で、二千十二年、Geoffrey Hinton博士が率いるチームがAlexNetという技術で他の参加者を圧倒する成績を挙げました。
これによってジーピーユーを使った機械学習が有効だということが証明され、今の大進展につながったんですよね。
ちなみにHinton博士は、ニューラルネットワークの基礎研究の功績で、二千二十四年にノーベル物理学賞を受賞しています。
Li博士はその後、スタンフォード大学で人工知能の研究に取り組み続けていましたが、二千二十四年に、言語ベースのエルエルエムとは異なるアプローチとなる「世界モデル」、World Modelの開発と商用化を目指してWorld Labsを立ち上げました。
私たち人間は「重いものは落ちる」「硬いものは跳ね返る」といった物理の法則を、小さいころに周りを見たり実際に物を投げたりして、感覚的に把握していますよね。
世界モデルというのは、そんな物理法則を学んだエーアイモデルのことなんです。
Li博士はこれに必要な感覚を「Spatial intelligence」、日本語だと空間知能と呼んでいるんですが、その感覚を得るには、エルエルエムのように文章を読ませるだけでは足りなくて、映像を使った学習が欠かせないと主張しています。
World Labsは九月にAtlasという最新の世界モデルを発表しました。
これは、テキスト、画像、映像を入力できて、それに基づいて映像や三次元シーン（たとえば3D Gaussian Splatや点群、深度マップなど）を作り出すエーアイモデルです。
技術的には「multimodal autoregressive diffusion transformer」と呼ばれるものだそうです。
通常のエルエルエムが「multimodal autoregressive transformer」で出力がテキストであるのに対して、Atlasは画像生成に使われているdiffusionの技術を取り入れていて、出力が映像や三次元シーンであることが大きな違いと言えるでしょう。
しかも入力された映像から、空間だけでなく時間の変化もモデル化できるため、ロボット向けのシミュレーション環境を作る、いわゆるリアル・トゥ・シムの用途も想定されています。
World Labsは、もともとMarbleという三次元モデリングのアプリケーションを一般向けに提供してきましたが、今後はMarbleがAtlasで動く予定だと発表しています。
例えるなら、ChatGPT（アプリ）とジーピーティー（モデル）の関係のように、Marbleが一般向けのアプリで、Atlasがその中で動くモデルという位置付けになるんですね。
Atlas自体は、現時点では一部のパートナー企業に限定した先行提供の段階です。
ちなみに、同じく現代エーアイの礎を作ったYann LeCun博士、画像認識で使われている手法「シーエヌエヌ」の生みの親の一人ですが、彼も同様の主張をしていて、世界モデルの開発を目指し、二千二十五年にAMI Labsというエーアイベンチャーを立ち上げています。
AMI Labsは、World Labsのような分かりやすいエーアイモデルはまだ発表していませんが、LeCun博士自身はニューヨーク大学の研究チームと共に、世界モデルに関する論文を積極的に発表しています。
たとえば、
[EN]Temporal Straightening for Latent Planning[/EN]
といった論文ですね。
いまのところは、エルエルエムを進化させ続けているオープンエーアイやアンソロピックなど数社が、エーアイモデルの最先端を走っています。
World LabsやAMI Labsの世界モデルに大きなチャンスがあると期待している人はまだごく少数ですが、今回のAMDによるWorld Labsの買収は、その流れを変える可能性を秘めており、非常に注目されています。
まずは、AMDのライバルであるエヌビディアの話からです。
エヌビディアは自動運転やロボットといったフィジカルエーアイを、次の成長戦略として重視していて、3Dシミュレーションやロボット向けのエーアイモデルなどの開発に力を入れているんです。
この観点から今回の買収を見てみると、AMDは「世界モデルがフィジカルエーアイの鍵を握る」という一つの「賭け」に出たと解釈することもできると思います。
つまり、今回の買収は「エルエルエム対世界モデル」、そして「エヌビディア対AMD」という二つの軸で捉えると非常に興味深いもので、こんごの発展にしっかりアンテナを張っておくべきだなと感じる事例になっています。
ここからは、[EN]OpenAI DevDay 2026[/EN]についてお話しします。
9月二十九日に、オープンエーアイが開発者向けのカンファレンス「DevDay 2026」をサンフランシスコで開催しました。
ここで二十以上の発表があり、その主な内容を紹介します。
まず最初にdotsです。
これはChatGPTの中で二十四時間動き続けるエージェントで、ジーピーティー-6 Astraで動作します。
それぞれに専用のクラウド上のコンピューターとブラウザが用意されていて、与えられた目標に向かって自律的に作業を続けてくれるんです。
Slack、Teams、さらには音声通話からも指示ができて、四千以上のアプリとも連携可能。
これはProとBusiness Premiumのプラン向けの機能です。
続いてジーピーティー-6.1 Solです。
こちらはジーピーティー-6 Astraに迫る性能を、およそ五分の一のコストで実現したお得なモデルになっています。
入力百マン・トークンあたり二ドル、出力は十ドルとなっています。
次はUltrafastです。
これは通常の六倍の料金で、最大六から八倍の速度、だいたい三百トークン毎秒という処理スピードを実現しています。
そしてPro 500。
こちらは月額五百ドルの新しいプランで、Plusの二十五倍の利用枠が使えるうえ、Ultrafastも利用可能となっています。
同時に、二百ドルのProプランは利用枠がPlusの二十倍から十倍に縮小されたという変更もありました。
エージェント向けの機能としてはAgentsエーピーアイ。
これにより、コードの実行やブラウザ操作、MCP接続、サブエージェントの並列実行などをオープンエーアイ側で管理してくれて、エージェント開発者にとってとても便利なエーピーアイになっています。
さらにDecisionsエーピーアイ。
ここではあらかじめ用意した選択肢の中から高速に分類を行ってくれるエーピーアイで、これは限定プレビューとして使えます。
[EN]ChatGPT Space / Pages[/EN]については、チームのメンバーとエージェントが一緒に作業できる共有ワークスペースや、人間とエージェントが同時に編集可能な文書エディタが紹介されました。
一番の目玉はやはりdotsです。
いままでのChatGPTは、人間が質問するたびに答えを返してくれる「受け身」なツールでしたが、dotsは人間が見ていない間も働き続ける「部下」のような存在になっています。
これによって、ChatGPTの主戦場がチャットから「エージェントに仕事を任せる」ことへと明確に移りつつあるのがわかります。
ビジネスの観点からとくに面白いのは、料金体系の変化です。
ジーピーティー-6.1 Solで「安い知能」を提供するいっぽう、Ultrafastや月額五百ドルのプランで「速さ」にはプレミアム価格をつけていて、既存の二百ドルプランの利用枠は半分に減らしています。
エージェントが二十四時間動くようになると、しょうひするトークン量が桁違いに増えるので、定額制のままだと採算が合わなくなっていることのあらわれだと私は見ています。
そして、Jevが発表されてからまだ二週間あまりしか経っていない中で、ここでDecisionsエーピーアイを発表できたのは本当に驚きなんです。
ゼロから作ったというより、既存のエルエルエムからトークンを生成する「Decode」という処理を省略して、選択肢の確率だけを返す形にしただけなんじゃないかなと思います。
ただ、それでもこれだけのスピードで対応できてしまうのは、今のエーアイ業界の競争の厳しさを本当によく表しているなと感じます。
使う立場としては、ジーピーティー-6.1 Solは大歓迎で、私もさっそく使っています。
毎日活用するモデルとして、性能と価格のバランスがとても良いんです。
Ultrafastはとても魅力を感じつつも、まだ月額五百ドルのプランには手を出していません。
一度使い始めたらやめられなくなりそうなのが一番の懸念点ですね。
続いて、ホワイトハウスの「Super Intelligence」サミットとエーアイ安全協定についてご紹介します。
DevDayと同じ9月二十九日に、ホワイトハウスではエーアイの将来に大きな影響を与えかねない、とても重要な会合が開かれました。
トランプ大統領とVance副大統領が、グーグルのピチャイ氏、アンソロピックのダリオ・アモデイ氏、メタのマーク・ザッカーバーグ氏、オープンエーアイのグレッグ・ブロックマン氏、xAIのイーロン・マスク氏、エヌビディアのジェンスン・フアン氏ら、エーアイ業界のトップを招いて行われた「Super Intelligence（超知能）」に関するサミットです。
なお、オープンエーアイのサム・アルトマン氏は招待を断って、代わりに社長のブロックマン氏が出席しています。
このサミットで発表されたのは二つです。
一つ目は「エーアイ安全協定」。
大統領と六社のトップが署名した「White House Accord on Super Intelligence」で、各社が自主的に安全対策を行うことを約束する一ページの合意文書です。
二つ目が大統領令で、連邦政府の機関に対しエーアイを「Super Intelligence（SI）」と呼ぶことを義務付け、六十日以内にSIの法的な定義案を作るよう指示しています。
それだけでなく、その数日前にはトランプ大統領としゅうきんぺい国家主席が、米中で超知能について話し合う対話の場、すなわちU.S.-China SI Dialogueを設けることでも合意し、十一月に初回の協議が予定されていることも発表されています。
この安全協定の中身は、各社が以下の「四層」の安全対策を実施するというものです。
まず、開発中や公開後のモデルの能力やアライメント、つまりエーアイが人間の意図に沿って行動しているかどうかを、サイバーセキュリティなどの観点から監視する社内の仕組みを持つこと。
その仕組みを監督する社内の専任チームを置くこと。
さらに、社外の独立した監査機関と提携すること。
そして、社内チームと社外監査の報告を審査する独立した委員会を設けるというものです。
米国政府と主要なエーアイ企業のトップが「リスクを真剣に受け止める」と公式に約束したのは大きな意味がありますし、米中の対話についても、冷戦時代に核戦争を防ぐために作られた米ソ間のホットラインを思い出させるようなものです。
エーアイの暴走は一国だけの問題じゃ済まないので、ライバル同士がしっかり話し合う場を持つことは不可欠だと感じます。
さいしょの一歩としては評価して良いと思うのですが、これだけでは不十分だという声もありますので、こんごも議論が続いていくと考えていいと思います。
ちなみに、エーアイを「Super Intelligence」と呼び変えるという大統領令も、なかなか興味深いです。
これは米国政府がエーアイを単なる便利な道具ではなく、人間を超える知能としてきちんと認識し始めたことを意味しています。
また同じ日に、連邦政府のサービスへの「玄関口」となるエーアイチャットボット「America.gov」も公開されました。
「こどものパスポートを取りたい」や「社会保障カードを再発行したい」といった用件を普通の言葉で質問すると、約二万九千ある政府のウェブサイトの情報をもとに、該当する手続きへと案内してくれるサービスです。
トランプ政権は何をやっても批判されがちですが、行政サービスの入り口をエーアイで一括化するという発想は理にかなっていて、日本政府にもぜひ参考にしてほしい取り組みだと思いました。
最後に、私が注目した記事を一つご紹介します。
[EN]White House unveils 'super intelligence' executive order and industry accord[/EN]
[EN]How does Trump's White House AI accord work?[/EN]
[EN]President Trump Participates in a Meeting and Luncheon on Super Intelligence（WhiteHouse.gov）[/EN]
[EN]U.S. and China Set Up Superintelligence Dialogue, First Talks in November[/EN]
[EN]OpenAI says its AI models escaped from a secure test environment and hacked into AI company Hugging Face in order to cheat on an evaluation[/EN]
[EN]Trump launches AI-fueled America.gov in bid to tie government services together[/EN]
続いて私の目に留まった記事についてです。
[EN]I'm sensing deep despair in academics over the past week[/EN]
こちらはニューヨーク大学でロボット研究をしているLerrel Pinto氏が、「この一週間、研究者たちのあいだに深い絶望感が漂っている」と書いた投稿です。
ジーピーティー-6 Astra、Claude Fable、Museといった最新の汎用エーアイモデルが、ロボット工学や世界モデルのベンチマーク、つまり性能を測るための共通テストを専用の訓練なしに次々突破したことへの反応をまとめている内容です。
特定の作業のためにデータを集めて、専用モデルを訓練して少しでも良い成績を出す、そんな積み重ねで成り立ってきた研究が、汎用モデルに一気に追い越されてしまった、という、そんな現場の率直な声が上がっています。
研究者の気持ちはとてもよく分かるんですが、やっぱり、課題ごとにいちいち専用の訓練をしなくても、初めて見る問題でもこなせる汎用性こそが、じつはエージーアイ、つまり汎用人工知能の本質なんです。
これは遅かれ早かれ、避けては通れない流れだと思います。
いっぽうで、気になるのが、上で紹介した「世界モデル」との関係ですね。
World LabsやAMI Labsといった会社は、エルエルエムの延長線上にあるモデルとはまた別に、世界モデルが必要だという立場なんですけど、汎用モデルがいまや世界モデルのベンチマークまで突破し始めている今、これから両者の関係がどうなっていくのか、とても興味深いところだなと感じます。
[EN]$5T opportunity: AI Roll Ups[/EN]
ここで取り上げたいのは、「エーアイロールアップ」と呼ばれるビジネスについてです。
これは、引退する経営者から小さなサービス会社を買い取って、エーアイエージェントで業務をガラッと作り変えて、利益率を大きく上げていく、そんな手法を、起業家のGreg Isenbergさんが「個人でもできる」と手順付きで解説した記事です。
基本的な考え方としては、普通なら五から十パーセント程度の利益率の会社を、三十から四十パーセントまで一気に引き上げることができるというもので、年商二百万ドル、およそ三億円規模の会社は、大手ファンドにとっては小さすぎるので、むしろ個人にこそ大きなチャンスが残っていると主張しています。
経営者の高齢化や後継者不足が深刻な日本こそ、こうしたチャンスがたくさん眠っているんじゃないかなと思います。
ただ、全く知らない業界の会社を買って、エーアイで業務を刷新するのは簡単なことではありません。
まずは、自分が今働いている業界でロールアップの対象になりそうな会社がないか調べてみる、あるいは自分の働いている会社、特に中小企業そのものにそういうチャンスがないか考えてみる、そんなところから始めるのが現実的だと思います。
[EN]Why I'm Building Muse[/EN]
続いて、メタの最高エーアイ責任者であるAlexandr Wangさんが、九月に公開したパーソナルエーアイエージェント「Muse」を作った理由について、自分自身の言葉で綴った文章です。
彼は、「ほとんどの人は、自分が本当に望んでいることを口に出さない」として、夢をしっかり言葉にして、そのための計画を立てて、メールや電話、スケジュール管理まで全部こなしてくれる「第二の頭脳」を全員が持つ、そんな世界を描いているんですね。
Museは公開から十二日間で、アメリカとカナダのApp Storeで二百八十万ダウンロードを記録し、同じ期間のChatGPTの実績を上回ったと報じられています。
いままで、エーアイエージェントといえばどうしてもChatGPTやClaude Codeばかりに注目が集まってきたんですが、FacebookやInstagramの膨大なユーザーベースを持つメタは、かなりユニークで有利な立場にいるなと思います。
とくに強みなのが、ユーザーの過去のデータを膨大に持っているという点です。
その人が本当に望んでいるものを見つけ出す「第二の頭脳」を作るためには、その人のことをよく知っていることが何よりもたいせつなんですね。
もしChatGPTを超えるような会社が現れるとしたら、それはメタなのかもしれません。
エーアイ native時代の袋小路 ─ 見立てる力はどこから来るのか
ここからは、エーアイが仕事の「中間工程」を肩代わりしていくことで、若い人たちが判断力、つまり物事を見立てる力を身につける場所そのものが失われつつある、という問題についてです。
これは安宅和人さんのエッセイで、ことし五月に公開されたものですが、最近読んでとても印象に残ったので紹介しておきます。
判断力というのは、伝票の処理とか契約書の読み込みみたいな地道な仕事の「副産物」として育ってきたものだ、という指摘です。
エーアイの出力を横で見ているだけだとなかなか育たない、としていて、エッセイの最後は「社会は確実に痩せる。
そしてその痩せ方は、しばらくの間、誰にも見えない」と結ばれています。
これは本当に重要な指摘だと思います。
実際、私自身も、未経験のエンジニアを雇うより、エーアイにコーディングを任せてしまっています。
でも、自分で手を動かしてコードを書いた経験のない人が、はたして優秀な「コーディング・エージェントの使い手」になれるのか…これは正直、大きな疑問が残ります。
ただし、C言語のコンパイラが登場した当時も、「アセンブリ言語、つまり機械語を人が読める形にしたものでプログラムを書いた経験のない人にCが使いこなせるはずがない」という声がありました。
結果としては、アセンブリ言語を知らないプログラマーが今や大多数になったわけで、今回も実際にどうなるかはまだ分からない、そんな気もします。
[EN]SEMICON Taiwan 2026: Optics[/EN]
[EN]Marvell Bought Celestial AI. How Far Along Is Photonic Fabric?[/EN]
次は、エーアイデータセンター内部の接続を銅線から光に切り替えていく「光接続」の現状を、それぞれ違う角度から分析した二本の記事です。
まず一本目は、台北で開かれた半導体製造の展示会、SEMICON Taiwan 2026での講演をまとめたレポートです。
チップのすぐ隣に光の部品を組み込むCPO、つまりCo-Packaged Opticsについて、二千二十七年に予定されている導入が遅れるとすれば、その理由は光の技術そのものではなく、光エンジンの検査能力の不足だろう、と指摘しています。
二本目は、Marvell社がことし二月に最大五十五億ドル、日本円だとおよそ八百三十億円で買収したCelestial エーアイの光接続技術「Photonic Fabric」が実際どのくらい完成しているのか、学会論文から読み解いた記事です。
光通信の性能測定と、パッケージ組み立ては、それぞれ別に実証されているものの、両方が揃った実測データはまだどこにも出ていない、と指摘しています。
エーアイの次のボトルネックは計算ではなく通信だ、というのは理論的にはその通りなんですが、こうした記事が示すように、実用化にはまだまだいくつものハードルが残っています。
どの技術、どの会社が主流になるのか、予想するのは簡単なことではありません。
ちなみに、光と電子の技術を融合させる「光電融合」というビジョンは、NTTが二千十九年に発表したIOWN、アイオン構想で、もうかなり前から掲げていることなんですが、それなのにNTTが実際にこのしじょうの舞台に上がって戦っているイメージがいまいちわかないのは、どうしてなんでしょうか。
ロシアの最新型ドローン「ゲラン4」
続いて、ロシアの最新型ドローン「ゲラン4」についてです。
ウクライナ軍が、ほぼ無傷で不時着したこのドローンを分解してみたところ、エンジンは中国製、制御チップはアメリカのTexas Instruments製など、重要な部品のほとんどが海外製だった、という中国語のXの投稿の話です。
「本当にロシア製と言えるのは外側の殻と最後の組み立てだけ」というわけで、経済制裁をしても民生品をかき集めれば高性能な兵器が作れてしまう現実がここに示されています。
ドローン技術は、まだまだ黎明期にありますが、こんごの戦いでは、自律型のドローンが「群れ」として自然言語でコントロールされる時代が必ずやってきます。
そこでカギを握るのは、妨害電波で通信が途切れても、ドローン自身が状況判断して作戦を遂行し続けられる仕組みです。
ちなみに、私は二千二十年に、まさにそういうドローン技術の会社をシアトルで立ち上げたことがありました。
でも、少し時代を先取りしすぎたことと、軍事転用への懸念もあって、ビジネスを少し別の方向にシフトしました。
[EN]Agentic commerce's impact on $AMZN and the ads industry[/EN]
ここからは、エーアイエージェントが人の代わりに買い物をする時代になったら、アマゾンや広告業界にどんな影響があるのかについてです。
これは投資家のFreda Duanさんが整理した投稿です。
人が商品ページを見ることがなくなれば、アマゾンの千億ドル規模の広告ビジネスは危うくなりますが、広告費そのものが消えるわけではなくて、「クリックごとの広告費」が「成約ごとの手数料」に形を変えるだけだ、という指摘です。
個人的には、広告の話よりも、エーアイエージェントが人間の代わりに買い物をする時代になったら、はたしてアマゾンのような巨大なショッピングポータル自体が必要なのか、という問いの方が面白いなと感じます。
もしエージェントが各ショップのサイトで直接買い物してくれるなら、お店が自社でネットショップを開設できる仕組みを提供しているShopifyが、これからどう動いてくるのかも見どころですし、あるいはまったく新しい形のエーアイネイティブなコマース・ベンチャーが登場してくるかもしれません。
今後の動向から目が離せません。
[EN]How AI Coding Agents Can Unlock Materials Simulation with NVIDIA ALCHEMI Toolkit[/EN]
[EN]Claude discovers a novel enzyme system[/EN]
最後は、エーアイエージェントが科学研究の現場で使われ始めていることを示す二本の記事です。
一つ目は、Claude Codeのようなエーアイコーディング・エージェントに、原子レベルの材料シミュレーションをどこまで任せられるのかを、エヌビディアが自社のツールキットを使って検証した記事です。
結果として、エージェントは物理的に正しい答えにきちんとたどり着く一方で、曖昧な指示を受けるとリチウムじゃなくてアルゴンのシミュレーションを書いてしまうなどの弱点も見られ、最終的に結果が物理的に意味のあるものかどうかは、やはり研究者自身が判断する必要がある、と結論づけています。
今回は週刊Life is beautiful、二千二十六年十月六日号からお届けします。
ここからは、「JevはLLMとどこが違うのか？
」や、「PFNの垂直統合戦略」、「AMDによるWorld Labsの買収」、そして「ホワイトハウスのAI安全協定」について取り上げていきます。
まず2本目の話題は、アンソロピックが発表した、約九百五十体のClaudeのエージェントが二十一時間かけて巨大なDNA配列データベースを調べ、遺伝子編集技術のCRISPR、つまり狙ったDNAを切ったり貼ったりできる仕組みに似た、新しい酵素のシステム「ART」を、ほぼ自律的に発見したという内容です。
人間が関わったのは、さいしょの指示と、どの候補を実験で確かめるかを判断したこと、そして実験室での作業でした。
こんご、医療や素材のぶんやでエーアイが大活躍することは間違いなく、今回ご紹介したこの二つの話題は、その良い例だと思います。
そういう意味でも、こんしゅうのざっくばらんでご紹介した「Matlantis PFP」には、大きなポテンシャルがあると私は見ています。
MatlantisもすでにClaude Code向けにSkillsを公開していて、エーアイエージェントが原子レベルのシミュレーションを使いこなす時代が、もう間近に迫っていると感じています。
[EN]Blue pigment pushes platinum-free fuel cell to record 902 mW/cm2 power density[/EN]
続いて、東北大学などの研究チームによるニュースです。
高価なしろがね、つまりプラチナの代わりに「青い顔料」を触媒として使った燃料電池で、世界最高レベルの出力を達成したという記事をご紹介します。
燃料電池のコストを大きく下げる可能性がある取り組みなので、取り上げることにしました。
使われているのは、フタロシアニン、これは青色の絵の具などに使われる合成顔料ですが、そこに鉄を組み込んだ分子になります。
この分子の構造を工夫して窒素を増やすことで、一平方センチメートルあたり九百二ミリワットという、この種の触媒としては過去最高の出力を実現したとのことです。
プラチナは一グラムあたり五十四ドル、およそ八千円もして供給量も限られているので、ありふれた材料で代用できれば、燃料電池の普及が大きく進むきっかけになりそうです。
ちなみに、触媒のかいはつは、先ほどご紹介したMatlantisがさいしょに取り組んだテーマでもあります。
こうした「身近な材料で高価な材料を置き換える」研究こそ、エーアイによるシミュレーションがもっとも威力を発揮する分野だと私は思っています。
[EN]Google's first orbital AI-chip test is in space[/EN]
次に、グーグルがエーアイチップを宇宙で動かす初めての実験衛星を打ち上げ、無事に動作していることを確認したというニュースです。
これは「データセンターを宇宙に作る」という構想が、いよいよ実証段階に入ったことを意味します。
今回、衛星に積まれているのは、グーグル製のAI専用チップ、ティーピーユーが四個で、データセンターのサーバー一台分ほどの計算能力です。
宇宙空間は空気がなく、冷却ファンも使えないため、熱は放熱板から赤外線として逃がすしかなく、Gemini、つまりグーグルのAIを十五分ほど動かしては止めて冷やす、という運用をしているそうです。
最終的には、およそ一万基の衛星を使って一ギガワット、これは原子力発電所一基分に相当する規模の計算基地を作る構想がありますが、現時点では地上の方が安価で、グーグルは今後打ち上げコストが下がることを期待しています。
ちなみに、今回はグーグルがSpaceXに衛星の打ち上げを依頼しています。
この構想が成立するかどうかは、打ち上げコスト次第であり、そのコストを大きく左右するのがStarshipを持つSpaceXです。
そういう意味でも、単なる打ち上げ発注にとどまらず、グーグルとSpaceXが今後、より幅広いかたちで提携する可能性も十分にあるのではないかと思っています。
ここからは質問コーナーに移ります。
【質問】
ピーター・ティールが好き、ということもあって、最近自分の中で「Zero to One エーアイ」というファンド名を勝手に作り、そのコンセプトに紐付けた企業でポートフォリオを作るのが楽しくて、毎日ちょこちょこ試しています。
ただ、その中で「Zero to One エーアイ」だと少し幅が広すぎるので、もう一段ずつ分解して投資対象を具体化したいと考えています。
「Zero to One エーアイ」のコンセプトとしては、単にエーアイで既存の業務が効率化される企業ではなく、「エーアイがあることで、これまで技術的・経済的にできなかったことが初めて実現可能になる領域」に注目するというものです。
個人的にはざっくり言うと、「AIの計算資源」と「その計算資源を利益に変える出口を持っている」企業であれば、将来大きなリターンに繋がるのでは、と考えています。
そのなかで、計算資源をリターンに変える事業として、
自動運転、
ロボティクス、
エーアイ創薬、
宇宙空間でのコンピュート、
それから、これまで人件費の問題で採算が合わなかった産業の自動化、
こうしたものが挙げられるのかなと思っています。
この中で、中島さんが特に注目されているトレンドや、何かヒントをいただけると嬉しいです。
《回答》
とても良い視点だと思います。
私も、ほぼ同じところを見ています。
あえて補足するなら、以下の通りです。
自動運転は、自動車だけでなく、ドローンや電車、列車にも応用が広がっていきますし、
エーアイ創薬だけでなく、新しい素材の開発にもエーアイの活用が期待されています。
またエーアイについては、半導体やアルゴリズムが進化することで、エッジ側の分野が大きく伸びる可能性も十分にあります。
【質問】
Hims & Hers Healthについて解説していただきたいです。
株を保有するべきか迷っています。
エーアイ創薬の分野で伸びる会社でしょうか？
《回答》
エーアイ創薬がこの先伸びるのは確実だと思いますが、Himsがその主役になれるかどうかは分かりません。
Himsの強みは、しょうひ者との繋がりなので、創薬そのものよりは、一人一人のニーズに合わせたパーソナライズド医療の窓口として成長する方向を目指していると考えていただくと良いと思います。
ちなみに、私は二年ほど前、知り合いがHimsで働き始めたタイミングで株を取得しましたが、その後は、買い増しも売却もしていません。
【質問】
（質問が長かったため、一部省略しています）
今回のJalapenoを見ていると、次は「半導体設計」という、高度な専門知識を要する分野でもエーアイが人間の知的作業の一部を置き換えていく流れが来るのでは、と思っています。
そこでお聞きしたいのは、
・この変化が半導体産業全体にどの程度のインパクトをもたらすか？
・エーアイ設計が進んだとき、最も価値が残る、あるいは価値が高まるレイヤーはどこだと考えられるか？
・投資家としてこのテーマを見る上で、参考になる人物や企業、資料など、何を追うべきか？
《回答》
エーアイを活用した半導体設計は、すでにエヌビディアでも進んでいますし、ソフトウェアで起きた変化と同じものが半導体設計にも起こりつつあります。
設計時間は短縮されるとはいえ、実動する半導体を作るまでには時間もコストもかかるので、今後は、そのプロセス自体をより早く、安価にする仕組みが重要になってきます。
後発のラピダスが業界で存在感を出すためには、まさにそこで勝負するしかないと、私は見ています。
たとえば、TSMCに頼むと半年で五千万円かかることが、ラピダスであれば一か月で一千万円で済む、といった差別化です。
当然、TeslaやSpaceXのTerafabもここを重視しているので、今後の発展に期待しています。
半導体設計が簡単になれば、チップそのものはコモディティ化していくので、エヌビディアが単なるチップビジネスからスーパーコンピュータビジネスにシフトしつつあるのは当然だと言えます。
私は、エヌビディアがTerafabの立ち上げに深く関わる、資金提供や予約注文を行うと見ており、そこは特に注目しています。
エーアイで半導体設計が簡単になったからといって、エヌビディアやBroadcomの競争優位が一夜にしてなくなることはなく、今後は、エーアイデータセンターを構築・運営するハイパースケーラーたちとの関係性がより重要になってくると考えます。
【質問】
私はエンジニアではありませんが、claude.codeを使って必要なアプリをいくつか作っています。
やり方としては、
ブラウザからclaudeに作りたいアプリの概要を伝えてお互いに意見交換し、ある程度かたちになったところで、claude.codeに渡すプロンプトを作ってもらいます。
その後、claude.codeにそのプロンプトを渡し、返ってきた回答をざっくり読んでコピペでclaudeに渡します。
そして、claudeからの回答をざっと読んでclaude.codeに戻す、といったやり方を繰り返しています。
もともとは、「ざっくり読む」部分をきちんと読んでいたのですが、プログラミングのことで分からない専門用語などが出てくると、完成までのスピードが落ちてしまうので、いまの方式に落ち着いています。
現時点では、不便を感じていませんが、いっぽうで「コピペだけで良いのだろうか？
」「もっと技術的なことも学んだ方がいいのではないか？
」と時々気になります。
「作りたいものをどうやったら実現できるか」や「よりおもしろいものにできないか」と考えている時間が自分のモチベーションなので、作る工程自体はコピペでもいいかな、とも思ってしまいます。
このやり方について、中島さんはどうお考えでしょうか？
《回答》
次のステップとして、gitの使い方を学び、Claudeの通常チャットやウェブサイトを経由せず、Claude Codeに直接依頼してコードを書かせ、かつgitでソースコードを管理すると、コピペの手間がなくなり、効率よくアプリが作れるようになります。
ぜひチャレンジしてみてください。
【質問】
普段より中島さんの発信を拝見しています。
今回はぜひご意見をお聞きしたいテーマがあり、ご連絡いたしました。
自動運転トラック企業のAurora Innovation、ティッカーAURに個人的に注目しています。
（以下、質問が続きます）
それでは、週刊Life is beautiful、二千二十六年十月六日号をお届けします。
今回のトピックは、「JevはLLMとどこが違うのか？
」「PFNの垂直統合戦略」「エーエムディーによるWorld Labsの買収」、そして「ホワイトハウスのエーアイ安全協定（パート6/6）」という内容です。
まず最初は、Aurora Innovationの株についてです。
二千二十六年時点の業績を見ると、株価は少し高すぎるかな、と個人的には感じているのですが、いくつかの観点から中長期的に株価が上がる可能性も感じています。
ですので、中島さんがこれをどう評価されているのか、ご意見をお聞きしたいんです。
私自身が注目している点としては、事業領域を都市部のロボタクシーではなく、拠点間、つまりハブ・トゥ・ハブの幹線物流に特化していることが挙げられます。
どのくらいマッピングコストがかかっているかは分からないのですが、都市部の複雑な環境に比べれば、高速道路中心の走行環境は、技術的な難易度や政治的な規制、それからマッピングコストの面でも有利じゃないかなと思っています。
それから、顧客が一般のしょうひ者ではなく物流会社である点も注目しています。
物流会社は「事故を起こさない」という安全性をとても重視する傾向が強いので、Lidarのような高額なセンサーを載せた車両であっても、安全性がきちんと実証されれば、導入コストは受け入れやすいのではないかと考えています。
また、創業陣や技術者に、WaymoとかTesla、Uber出身の著名なエンジニアが数多くいる点もポイントだと思っています。
技術力がかなり高くて、それが商用化のスピードや競争力につながっているのでは、という見方です。
こうした視点についてどう思われますか？
また投資対象として、あるいは技術トレンドとして、中島さんはAuroraや自動運転トラック業界全体をどのように評価されていますか？
ぜひご意見をお聞きしたいです。
それでは中島さんからの回答です。
私はAurora Innovationについて特に詳しいわけではないんですが、株も持っていません。
ただ、「長距離トラックこそ自動運転車が必要で、それが実現するのは時間の問題」、「人を雇う代わりに自動運転トラックで輸送サービスを提供する会社が複数生まれる」という、この二つについてはほぼ確信しています。
今年になって、ようやくTeslaがTesla Semiの大量生産に本格的に乗り出したこともあり、今後五年ほどのあいだに、長距離輸送ビジネスは大きく変化するだろうと私は見ています。
Auroraについて言えば、VolvoやPACCARなどのパートナー企業がどれくらいのスピードでAuroraの技術を搭載した自動運転トラックを、実際のしじょうに送り込むか、そしてTeslaと戦い続ける体力があるか。
また、Tesla Semiを使った輸送サービス会社が複数誕生した場合、Auroraがどのように対抗していくのか、それから「一マイルあたり八十五セント」でライセンスするビジネスモデルが本当に成り立つのか、などが重要なポイントだと思います。
ここからは別のご質問に移ります。
今回の内容で、「薬剤師の資格を取るのに何が必要か私は知りませんが、本やパソコンで勉強しただけで取れる資格は今後価値がなくなると考えた方がいいと思います。
一方で、医師、特に外科医や電気工事士のように手を動かすことが必要な資格は、長く価値が続くのではないでしょうか。
」という話がありました。
イーロン・マスク氏が、テスラのヒューマノイドロボット「Optimus」やエーアイを使うことで、三年から五年以内にロボットが人間の一流外科医を上回る手術を行うようになると予測している中、私は外科医として少し安心しました。
個人的には、どんなにロボット外科医が進歩しても、手術のスタートボタンを押す仕事は法律上外科医の仕事として残るんじゃないか、と周りには冗談まじりに話しています。
（もし本当にそうなったら、ちょっと寂しいですが）。
もし機会があれば、この点について中島さんの展望もお聞かせいただけるとうれしいです。
ここからは中島さんのご回答です。
エーアイがまず人間の知的労働を代替し、次にエーアイを搭載したロボットが肉体労働を代替するという流れから考えると、いずれ外科手術もロボットが行う時代が来る、つまりロボットがやった方が安くて、正確で、安全というのは時間の問題だと思います。
手術ロボット「ダ・ビンチ」を提供しているIntuitive Surgicalは、しじょうにある「ダ・ビンチ」から実際の手術映像やデータを収集していて、それをエーアイの学習データに使うのは当然の流れです。
外科医の仕事が「手術開始のボタンを押す」だけになる未来は、冗談みたいに思えるかもしれませんが、ソフトウェアエンジニアの仕事が「コードを書く」から「エーアイにどんなソフトウェアを作るか指示する」仕事に移行したことと同じように、外科医の仕事も「この患者にはどんな手術が必要かを決める」だけになっていく、そんな未来も十分に考えられます。
続いて、投資比率についてのご質問です。
一般的な投資本では「特定の銘柄がポートフォリオの二十〜三十パーセントを超えたらリバランス、つまり一部利益確定をすべき」とよく推奨されています。
けれども、中島さんのように大きく化けた銘柄を長期で持ち続けるスタイルだと、結果的に少数の銘柄にかなり比重が偏ることもあると思います。
企業の技術的優位性が保たれている限り、一つの銘柄がポートフォリオの過半数を占めるようになっても一切リバランスせずに持ち続けますか？
もしくは「〇割を超えたら調整する」といった上限のルールはありますか？
中島さんの回答です。
私は特にリバランスはせず、気に入った株はそのまま持ち続けています。
次はエーアイ時代のスマホのメモリ容量についてのご質問です。
先日、iPhone 18 Proが発表されました。
17 Proからの進化点としては、Neural Acceleratorsが六コアジーピーユーから七コアジーピーユーになったり、Neural Engineが十六コアからデュアル十六コア、つまり合計三十二コアになった、などとされています。
でも、メモリ容量は十二ギガバイトのままで据え置きです。
二年前からハイエンドモデルのPixelには十六ギガバイトのメモリが載っていることもあって、グーグルとはちょっと温度差を感じました。
中島さんは以前からパソコンのメモリ容量にはこだわっていましたが、スマホは当面十二ギガバイトで十分だと思いますか？
それとも今後、エーアイ時代のスマホにはさらに大容量のメモリが必要になるとお考えですか？
iPhoneはソフトウェアアップデートも含めて長く使えますが、メモリ容量は後から増やせないので気になって質問しました。
これに対する中島さんの回答です。
パソコンのメモリ容量は実際に仕事をする際のパフォーマンスと直結するので重視していますが、スマートフォンの場合は十二ギガバイトで十分なんじゃないかと思います。
アップルは、今世の中に出回っている古いiPhoneでも使えるようなアップデートをしてくるので、すぐに古くなってしまう心配はあまりありません。
ちなみに、アップルがメモリを十二ギガバイトに据え置いたのは、最近のメモリ価格の高騰の影響が大きいです。
この影響は、次のモデルが発表される来年まで続く可能性が十分にあります。
最後は、生成エーアイのプランについてのご質問です。
私は零細企業の経営者で、生成エーアイの利用は私ひとりです。
生成エーアイのプランはすべて法人向けプランを契約されていますか？
個人向けでも有料プランなら学習利用禁止の設定にはできるものの、やはり法人プランにしておいた方がいいのでしょうか？
中島さんの回答です。
一人で使うのであれば個人向けのプランで十分だと思います。
私自身も、私の会社の仕事で使ってはいますが個人向けのプランにしています。
以上、週刊Life is beautiful、二千二十六年十月六日号でした。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。